we have something in common I admire
really good political comedy I don't do
it as much we don't do it as much on
this show because it's just not as much
in my wheelhouse
I like you know things that are pretty
silly things that are pretty universally
at goofy eye I noticed that back on your
show in the car Burnett show you didn't
do a lot of political comedy and they
were very political times they were but
that really wasn't my bag I'm a clown
and that's what I got
just belly laughs if you can't as we
went on you know we got a little more
serious with some of the sketches like
the family that we did and you know but
still that was a lot of fun but it never
occurred to me to be political I really
wasn't thinking about it just wasn't my
bag and I think that's why our show is
still viable
you know 50 years later you look at some
of the sketches and funny is funny well
it's also you know it's it's funny you
say that because true story I think was
a couple of days ago and they they crop
up all the time you can channel surf now
looking at different things and I came
across your show and I just started
watching it and yeah it was no no I was
on television you should be getting paid
and and I everything was really making
me laugh also their shot it was shot
very well you know
the videotaped quality is so good that
it looks like it was shot about three
weeks ago well yeah as I say it holds up
the only time you can tell it you know
it's all the time that went by is that
the clothes and the hairdos yeah all of
that you know that big one point you
came out and you're talking to the
audience and they cut to a reverse shot
and you could see the audience and men
had sideburns that came off there okay
all right 70s yeah
people have ties right land a plane but
yeah but I found all the humor is it's
as funny today as it was then because
you don't need to know specific
references exactly that's why I mean I
dare anybody to watch the Dennis sketch
with Tim and Harvey and not just laugh
themselves silly and that's about 45
years old yeah yeah people still talk
about that
you